what was reported I think was 30 to
Connor and 100 to Floyd was that what
was reported I think it was hot for
certainly higher for Conor that I know
and and you know for Floyd I would
imagine it would be probably around
there or higher just depending on what
he did again wow do you really think
that 100 million was true well I mean I
I Connor was on you know I'd say
just under a hundred right when it's all
said and done so that's his part so
again he has a part we had a partner in
the UFC so and I will get into the
specifics but yeah so for Floyd's side
it's very reasonable to think that he
could have pulled in a hundred uh
assuming that he he didn't take it all
[Music]
Audi I I I see all these interviews with
you I see you on the UFC like behind the
scenes stuff and you're always wearing
slick suits and you're dressed nice
right now but I just saw that you're
drinking out of a Stanley mug just to
remind everyone at home that no matter
how fancy someone is we all have a
little basicness inside of us you know I
always say like you know it's business
much like sports you have to you know
you wear your uniform to play the game
right okay but we're all human at the
end of the day we all have our casual
clothes or you know our at home I've
only seen one interview you and I've
watched a bunch of interviews there's
only one interview that you weren't
wearing a suit you're wearing like
Lululemon and a hat the only time I'm
gonna have to switch it up now man
that's it you know I have to switch it
up but it's a pleasure to meet you guys
man you should Zig and zag the other way
because I think a lot of people in the
like agents talent management they all
are all like very slick looking you
should go the other way right like um
you should go athleisure as your main
thing because you were an athlete so I
feel like you can pull that off and a
lot of guys in that space will all look
like suits to you know in comparison I'm
gonna have to man I'm gonna have to to
make people remember that I was actually
one of them before I became a suit
exactly well there there was some bum
out there in San Francisco who was the
first person to wear just like you know
pajama bottoms and a t-shirt instead of
a suit you you just that's that that's
your burden now I guess I was from Cali
too so I gotta start just rocking
flip-flops you know what I mean just
just all good with the flip-flops in the
shorts in Silicon Valley uh it's like
the opposite like I remember when I
first moved here I went to like this
nice kind of like Club Speakeasy type
thing and everybody's waiting in line
and a guy walks up with a hoodie and you
know it just looks completely disheveled
and the bouncers know like all right
this guy's either homeless or a
billionaire we don't know which one we
gotta just err on the side of maybe this
is like the next Mark Zuckerberg let him
in let them in first and go that way I
realized oh the status game is
different here
that's funny I heard a lot about that
yeah certainly uh Counter Culture if you
go to business the noble the New York
the New York hustle is all suit and tie
whereas the San Francisco hustle is
definitely flip-flops and and holes in
your T-shirt you know
so your introduction here is it's it's
it's there's you've got a bunch of stuff
so so you've started Paradigm which is
uh and you just call it an agency a
sports agency sports management company
I'd say it's a Sports Management
entertainment platform it's what it is
platform all right with uh the most
famous guy being Conor McGregor but I
also think you have Izzy do you have one
more champion on there I thought you had
three so Izzy's a former client of ours
but definitely was an amazing client
while he was with us uh Michael Bisping
uh Stephen Thompson Michael Ben and
Paige Rico verhuven uh past clients
obviously like Chris Lytle who's
actually one of my first clients that's
how I got into the sport
um but yeah very fortunate to work with
some of the the greatest fighters of all
time though yeah so just a bunch of
Ballers but then you also co-founded
proper 12 which we're gonna ask you all
about it but according to the headlines
it was like a 600 million dollar exit so
you've had some maybe even more success
there than the main thing what's cool is
uh so you run a a talent kind of like
let's say what part of your business how
talent management talent agency and
that's cool there's a bunch of our
audience that also owns agencies which I
think is great but what I liked about
you is that you have also kind of the
Venture side so you're like creating
Brands and business ventures off the
talent and we've talked about these kind
of Creator brands in the past we had uh
you know Mr Beast on here and he's got
all these kind of like feastables he's
got other uh you know corporate Brands
underneath it we had a Instagram star
Danny Austin come on and she's got Divi
like a hair care brand that's doing you
know way more money than she can get
kind of just in in versus like
influencer brand deals and so what I
like is that you've got and Rob Dyrdek
yeah Rob Dyrdek you've got both and
that's been a theme that we've kind of
been
been playing with so I think we'll we'll
try to hop around a little bit but I
definitely bless you bless you I mean
I'll be remiss if I didn't give you
those two sorry oh wow what a gentleman
look at that
hello John May edit it out and and then
yeah that's that's a character shower
right there
I'm like I'm talking if Sam's dying over
there I'm gonna finish my point I don't
care oh yeah he's good he'll come back
yeah exactly no no I appreciate the
recognition look I mean we we certainly
I feel were one of the early
um you know platforms slash agencies if
you will that really saw not only
um you know an opportunity but more so
wanted to do more for our clients right
we wanted to disrupt our respective
industry but also think far beyond that
and not just think transactional and for
me in mixed martial arts it was an
underserved market and we wanted to not
only advocate for our clients but
advocate for the school for it really
push fighter fighter uh not only
earnings uh higher and higher which
still have a long way to go but they've
come a long way from when we first
started and back in 2009 in in the sport
and we were very fortunate because we
came in right before the first
um you know rights deal was was actually
paid you know the UFC was paying to be
on Spike prior to the fox deal and and
as you know most people know that's the
main economic driver of any professional
sports organization whether it's the you
know NFL the NBA and now obviously from
from a mixed martial arts perspective
the UFC they were paying Spike to put
themselves on TV that's a that's
publicly no they were actually you know
paying for that air time so the original
Ultimate Fighter and then all all that
was broadcast on Spike back in the day
um yeah they were not only funding their
own production but they're paying for
that air time and and fox was that
really first paid deal that the UFC uh
garnered you know and which was a
Monumental uh milestone for the sport
and and for the promotion and sport of
mixed martial arts you know is is it
wouldn't be here without the UFC which
is the Catalyst but where the sport is
today now you have other promotions that
are competing and promotion is very
synonymous with leagues right so when
you talk about leagues
um you know it's there's certain
terminologies within the sports world
that are very similar although there's a
lot of differences as well right in
terms of you know athletes in NFL MBA
being employees and then Fighters being
independent contractors so for us we saw
an opportunity of it not only being the
fastest growing sport in an underserved
market for the athletes but then also
really Thinking Beyond just management
how can we create you know more value
for the clients and you know it takes a
special client and a special personality
like Conor McGregor so I was very
fortunate to sign him 10 years ago and
you know and and we had a vision and he
was very very bullish about that Vision
as well let's rewind let's rewind to
that so you uh your story is kind of
I'll give the first part very fast so
you you play football at UCLA you end up
getting injured you move into uh
management side of things you got you
got some kind of football players as
your first clients and then you Branch
into MMA and you discover Conor McGregor
can you tell the story how did you how
did you discover Connor what was what
was his situation like at that time and
uh well what was those kind of the first
meeting it takes us back to those days
yeah sure so
um I think taking it back to the first
days the early days is really working
with guys like Chris Lytle right getting
into the business
um we're working with the guy that I got
to work with him for one fight and he
retired so then it was being able to
sign Michael Bisping which was a massive
opportunity for me and someone that I'm
so proud of not only as a client but as
a friend as well who went on to be the
first British uh Champion first champ
UFC champion from uh from the UK and you
know he was a pioneer of mixed martial
arts for all the up-and-coming athletes
within Europe you know Ireland included
so
um I was very fortunate enough to start
to work with Michael and and other
clients as well earlier in my in my uh
career in in the UFC and mixed martial
arts in particular
um and so when I signed Conor was when
he first came on to to the to the UFC
scene right he was fighting in the
region no promotion in Europe cage
Warriors which is still around and he's
still uh you know they what's called a
mid major if you will and these are
these are to some extent they're
professional promotions but they're
feeder programs and the larger
promotions if you will and um he had
just signed to the UFC and we were
introduced uh interestingly in us like
through Facebook and you know at the
time it was he was you know looking at
signing with one of the agencies in the
sport and I got an opportunity to uh
pitch him and and Coach his coach John
Kavanaugh as to why I felt that we would
be the best fit for him and so you gotta
you know put you know put your best foot
forward and and give it a shot and and
hopefully you win that business and I
was fortunate enough that
um you know we got first opportunity
actually to work with him heading into
his you know his first fight we were
saying okay well let's pause now let's
talk after this first fight so he beats
Marcus brimage was that the uh baby yeah
that's the famous line that fight and
after that his second flight was his U.S
debut actually against Max Holloway and
we started to work with with one another
um heading into that fight and so um the
rest is history but one of the things
you know we recognize is not only his
athletic ability but then he had special
special not only talent in inside the
Octagon but you could tell he was very
special and charismatic he had that it
factor that you know is is you know I
think it's it's once in a it's once in a
generation type of of an athlete as well
not only from a physical perspective but
a qualitative perspective and so you
know the sky was going to be the the
limit in terms of what we could do
together and was that I mean I've seen
all the there's these older interviews
where Connor still has acne he has no
tattoos and he says like you know mark
my words you will see me in the UFC you
will see me as a champion one day and
then coming up leading up to that Marcus
fight and then I think it was Dennis
silver in Boston if I remember correctly
like in the early days you still see
that he has some type of star power on
camera but behind the scenes uh even at
a young age in his early 20s did you
notice that uh the confidence and the
star power was there just in your normal
hanging out sessions yeah you could
definitely see his Charisma behind the
scenes and uh you know he was like I
said he was very witty uh very very
confident but also very engaging you
know I think one of the things I always
Chelsea Bros you know majority of people
in the world uh know who Conor McGregor
is and I would argue that most of them
have never seen him fight they've
actually seen more of his interviews and
and and
um and him talking because you know when
he talks you can't take your eyes off it
awesome right he's just so fun and
whether you love him or hate him you're
watching him you know and that's that's
I think what makes him special
yeah you find a Conor is kind of like
we've had guys on this podcast that are
like yeah I discovered Uber I was like
the fifth investor in Uber or you know
like they're early investors in Facebook
or something like that right it's like a
it's like an angel investment that goes
on to become this is what we call in
Silicon Valley like a unicorn right
that's like this billion dollar brand
that you discover at that early age were
were other people pitching in for
business at that time because I remember
that first brimage fight there was like
a hype around him like even his entrance
people were like really excited about
him and
I didn't know who he was at the time so
I don't even know how people were so
excited about the guy at that time so I
imagine that
you know there were other agents trying
to win that business at that time
um do you have any good fun anecdotes or
stories of like your hustle at that time
to get him or was it like no people it
was kind of like a like an ignored asset
people didn't realize that this was
going to be that he was going to be a
big deal and it really was it didn't
look like it was like this hotly
contested thing no I definitely think
that people were were
um you know hot on him but I think
everybody was pitching him on the same
idea it was more transactional and I
think what were
um I stood out surely was because I I
had a broader Vision I had brought a
vision of creating IP you know and
creating media and content but also
creating uh business ventures right and
I really was bullish in on that idea uh
and I I remember even when I first
launched Paradigm 2009 my business plan
was not only to be the best in class
from a management perspective but build
uh clients media and IP where whereby
building more brand equities for them
and that will yield not only more ants
they wrote up and used from a
sponsorship perspective but increased
their value from a from their playing
contract or prospective athletically and
also leads to to business ventures and
you know I I was laughed at when I first
had that business plan it's too busy
focused on what you could do you know
like and and I think that that's what
stood out to him because he had that
vision for himself as well and
um it was even if you think about what
we did back in 2017 with the Floyd fight
I mean everybody thought we were crazy
you know that that fight was never going
to happen and everybody doubted us
everybody even some of those ended up
doing the deal and partnering with us so
ultimately you know we had to believe in
ourselves and and more importantly go
out and actually execute right because
you could have dreams you could have
visions you could start something but if
you don't execute successfully it means
nothing and now that trend is common
those exhibitions now are commonplace
you see everybody now taking place in
these exhibitions and there's an
appetite from a consumer perspective for
these unique matchups where people are
are uh matched up from from different
sports just uh to compete in Combat
Sports
um and then we even launched our Venture
on the back of that we launched proper
2018 and so you know again at that time
I think it was maybe uh George Clooney
and and maybe Puff Daddy at the time you
know but I don't think anybody else now
it's like Spirits everybody has some
type of a liquor brand that they're
they're hopping and and then Ventures is
commonplace as well so you know to me
I'm proud of the fact that we had this
vision and we were able to execute more
importantly you know because
um it's very hard to do it's
hand-to-hand combat every day
entrepreneurship I uh I want to ask you
about the proper 12 stuff but before
that so like I grew up watching
Entourage and so you see like Ari
Emmanuel or Ari Gold dealing with like
crazy young actors who have monies and
money and it's like you know drugs and
sex and then Ballers it's like uh drugs
and sex as well but the difference
between uh you know Ballers what's NFL
but then there's the difference I
imagine
with UFC fighters where it's you're not
an actor you're not a player you're
gonna get out there in your underwear
and fight to the death in front of
millions of people
can you like tell me a little bit about
the difference between managing someone
like Connor or an Izzy like these like
because I imagine them are they crazy
what's that mindset like on a daily
basis in that mentality particularly
when it comes to business are they have
you found that you have to hold them
back from being so aggressive sometimes
or what's that like with that type of
athlete well first of all I don't think
they're crazy per se so it's not you
know because of the profession or the
sport that they're in that that they
tend to be maybe a little bit
um you know
crazy so to speak right I mean like when
I say crazy I mean like high risk or
whatever high risk I think look it means
depending on the field you're in it's
that's subjective what you think high
risk and not most totally most people
that come from let's say if you're a
neurosurgeon you're going to think the
Combat Sports is super high risk right
but ultimately I think every human being
is different they're certainly there's
certainly when you're that competitive
you're gonna be driven you're gonna be
more aggressive and I think I see it
even in business at the same at the
highest level there's there's that
chip on the shoulder there's that edge
that that every high level competitor
has whether it's an athlete in different
sports or whether it's a businessman or
woman in at the highest level of their
respective field so obviously business
Acumen varies right so if you're talking
about an Institutional Investor versus a
professional athlete diverse but even
within the sport you have athletes to
have a very high level business Acumen
Founders not trained from an
Institutional perspective he didn't go
get his MBA he doesn't have that that
academic background if you will right
but he's a very natural businessman
what's a what's a story as an example I
mean his story is proper 12. I mean
could it easily taken a check from a
sponsorship perspective and been so
short-sighted as opposed to putting up
our own Capital initially finding the
right operating partner finding the
right strategic Capital supply chain
rapid Market going out and creating our
own working without getting the
sponsorship checked for x amount of
posts or why amount of appearances if
you will for an ultimate windfall that
changes life and is generational well so
that in itself is a great example did
you guys have like Jameson we're like
hey we want to sponsor you and you were
like dude this Connor let's do our
own thing he's always had a desire to
get into whiskey it's it's like he's
Irish it's part of the DNA right and his
his grandfather was a was a whiskey man
and we always had the idea when we were
approached by a sponsor and and it was
like do we go and pursue a sponsorship
and take a check or do we just go and
own our own business and when you study
the category and looked at the tab and
you looked at the opportunity you're
like we could this is right for
disruption we actually could really come
in and do something here right and so
that that's a perfect example of his
natural business acting right because
it's hard to do that especially at that
level he wasn't making you know a ton of
money yeah up until we got to the Floyd
fight which is by the way when we
announced our entry into the market we
announced our entry into the whiskey
Market in our post by press conference
yeah I remember he's cold in the glass
we started though the process in 2014
and we were doing a lot of research and
development and pivoting from different
groups and and ultimately we we found
the right you know formula if you will
on the right team Etc right
um and and the rest is history and that
to me takes a lot of a lot of
intelligence for an athlete to do that's
not trained how does it have the
experience of building a business and
you know more moreover the patients
right to really bet on himself how much
of your guys's Capital did you put up to
get it off the ground and do you
remember what your first year sales was
what what was well I'll tell you I can't
disclose all the information just
through the strict confidentiality
Provisions that exist with our partners
and our acquire so I I got to be safe
but I can tell you that we put up
probably a few hundred thousand of our
own Capital initially I could say that
right
um and that's you know I mean that most
of that went to lawyers if you will just
before or you can get started so
um but it's like strategically I think
the way we set it up and we have great
Partners you know one of our partners is
uh and is an operating genius and is a
wizard in the spirits business can
Austin so I gotta give him a shout out
because I yeah he had another company
right I mean he did Avion then he yeah
probably does he's got a terramata now
he's in the Lolo he's a he's a he's a
Jeep when it comes to experience
business you know and when you find
people like that are you doing just like
a like a 30 30 like you know you guys
all split Equity evenly I can't go into
the details of the cap table I wish I
could but again the strong
confidentiality Provisions in all
agreement but it was a it's a fair deal
and I think everybody's happy in the end
but moreover you bring on a black belt
that knows what they're doing because at
the end of the day that's part of
operating a business and being
successful it's like you know what you
don't know but essentially no matter
what cap table looks like you're gonna
make sure you bring on that the right
expertise right from an operational
perspective you have to have all the
right ingredients to be able to execute
successfully so even with something like
that let's say uh just to put this in
perspective is it the decision to say
well we could just take a straight
sponsorship deal get a check make a few
Instagram posts and and you know cash
that check
um versus we're gonna do the
entrepreneurial work and actually build
a brand the payoff difference I imagine
you could tell me from I think it's
probably a hundred to one would that be
approximate so like you know if you just
say okay over a few years we would have
a a kind of an alcohol sponsor and we're
we're doing you know kind of these these
scheduled posts with them or commercials
with them or whatever it may be I think
it's probably something like 50 to 100 x
bigger return by doing the work is that
I would say it's a more it's a multiple
of that you think
a few hundred dollars how much would a
sponsor should have been I mean I mean
back in that back at that time you know
when we first started the process it
would have been like 250 000 something
like that that would have been a big one
by the time we launched he probably was
in the seven figure range yeah in terms
of sponsor sponsorship annually right
that's like an annual deal annual deal
right yeah okay so a million some some
Millions per year in order to promote
yeah a whiskey versus hundreds of
millions yeah exactly so I would say I
would say like it was you know you could
run any you know analysis even in an npv
and look at like how we won and won big
you talked about the Mayweather McGregor
thing how that came to like how that
nobody thought that that was going to
happen and then it it actually happened
and it was kind of amazing I remember
vividly where I was I remember I was I
was in Australia and I had to get up at
a certain time I was at a bar at like
five in the morning or something like
that to watch that fight
um but I also remember the build up like
there was the kind of back and forth
almost flirting on on social media
talking talking trash to each other to
try to generate interest because I think
both guys Floyd and Conor are probably
the two smartest businessmen ever that
come through Combat Sports and they kind
of knew okay this is the right dance
partner from for us to like execute
something orders of magnitude bigger
than what we could do and um and I
remember at the time it was seen as
almost like the the Elon musk's Mark
Zuckerberg thing today or it's like wow
that'd be crazy if it happened but
there's no way I mean just to get all
these people to get them everyone to
agree
um seemed impossible can you take us
back like uh you know like I see all
these videos of you like hanging out at
Connor's house or whatever and like you
get you know the behind the scenes stuff
there had to have been just like a couch
conversation where you guys are like
okay could we do this how could we do
this what what was that early days like
before it came to fruition so I to your
point I think you know you have two of
the smarter s and Savvy businessmen in
Combat Sports that really understood
you know the modern day fandom of both
sports right and early days like he
wants to do it and then it would be shot
down by UFC by by members of the media
by whoever that just doubted that it
would ever happen
um and I think that the the banter is
really what allowed it to happen because
once they started going back and forth
and you could actually see the level of
Engagement and interest from a market
perspective and from a consumer
perspective
it was hard to deny it right it was hard
to deny it because it was like this is
real it's viable it's a it's a win-win
scenario and a win for all parties
should be involved why not right the
fans want it the fighters want it and
and moreover the numbers were speaking
for themselves from an analytics
perspective so that allowed us to really
use
what the two fighters were intelligently
doing on a very instinctive level right
there wasn't planned there wasn't
scripted it was very instinctive but
moreover I think what what my job is is
to look at the data and be like right
there's something very viable here
there's something that you know you have
to be able to take and continue to to
Advocate and push for your client
because you could effectively have a
successful business opportunity even for
the UFC and so that I think it took them
a while to come around but eventually
they did because they realized there was
just such
amazing and intense interest around this
event that it was real it wasn't a
gimmick it was something that everybody
wanted to see and so I think that was uh
credit to them too because again it went
against all their their their normal
business practice they'd never done
something like that before and it took
you know I think for them to see the
substance of it all to then move forward
with us and ultimately it was a huge
success I mean over four million buys I
mean I think there's probably there's a
something there was some
um report I remember receiving it was we
had like hundreds of millions of illegal
streams I mean like
and we still did over 4 million buys you
know what I mean like so could you
imagine if like it was the most
bootlegged fight ever yeah if we would
have just been able to even just plug
some of those holes and how many more
buys we would have had right but I mean
it was such a commercial success I mean
can I ask you a quick question about
those buys yeah so you said you said
four million buys I'm not I'm not
attacking this strictly about this fight
but when I see pay-per-view numbers like
what the headlines are I think most of
them are complete I think that
with a fighter says like for example I
remember Floyd has multiple times said
he's earned nine figures so 100 plus
million off of one one fight and uh I
think I think Connor say I think he was
just talking but he's like oh I'm
making this much money off this um
uh cowboy Cerrone fight I think those
are nonsense and the reason I think
they're nonsense is it's almost like a
rapper bragging about how much money
they have it's like part of the brand
you're not he's part of your brand and
also no one's incentivized like Dana or
Showtime or HBO they're not incentivized
to like tell the public that yeah this
dude's full of we gave him two
million dollars he didn't earn 20
million dollars off this thing oh boy no
look let me just look at that public
information that's a loaded because
there's certain elements of that you
know could be hypothetically true but
for example compensation is not fully
reported
when you're talking about UFC
particularly MMA like but that's not
fully reported what the persons really
are at the highest level that yeah you
know what I mean so so it's actually
more it's even that true because I it's
just what's reported to the commission
and assuming that they don't have let's
call it another agreement so that's
actually in terms of pay-per-view
there's a speculation so for example May
Mac in particular There Was You know I
think there was rumors that were
starting to trickle in that it did over
six million buys or something to that
extent you know what I mean but it
landed in like the four three four four
range and that's that no that's actual
right I mean ultimately you know that's
those are not fudge numbers and so what
you were hearing about what potentially
uh Conor made and potentially Floyd made
on our side I know it's more true on the
Floyd's side I don't know if he divulges
who he splits it with or if you know
what that what that looks like on his
side so I can't comment on on his right
but UFC was our partner so I know what
they're what we're reporting for kind of
was Connor's what was reported I think
was 30 to Connor and 100 to Floyd was
that what was reported I don't think so
but maybe I mean in terms of what you're
talking about reported to the the
commission of the papers no no
journalist ever actually like breaks
that down you know what I mean so that's
what I'm saying like these numbers are
so high and I hear that and I was
walking around for I think it was hot
for certainly higher for Conor that I
know oh and and you know for Floyd I
would imagine it would be probably
around there or higher just depending on
what he did again wow do you really
think that 100 million was true well I
mean I I Connor was on you know I'd say
just under a hundred right when it's all
said and done so and that's his part so
again he has a part we had a partner in
the UFC so and I won't get into the
specifics but yeah so for Floyd's side
it's very reasonable to think that he
could have pulled in a hundred uh
assuming that he he didn't take it all
didn't have partnership but that's right
you're a business guy so you see what
Floyd did in the boxing business where
he basically became his own promoter
runs his own runs his own ship so that
he can take the Lion's Share of of the
the revenue or the profits that come
from an event where like in the past
guys like Mike Tyson and others sort of
got screwed because they're out there
fighting generating all this demand then
they look at 10 years later they're like
where's all the money and the promoter
is basically enriched themselves in that
way and obviously the UFC is totally
different it's like a league it works
differently but a guy like Connor is
essentially as big of a brand as the USC
or UFC uh like you know let's say it's
debatable they're in the same like the
same like air and if Conor McGregor was
to go do a fight on YouTube pay-per-view
or whatever he wanted to do he could
pull the same numbers as a UFC card
without the UFC's promotion do you think
like I guess when you see what Floyd did
do you think anybody's ever going to do
that with the UFC or in MMA where
they're going to become their own
promoter and have their own shows I
think the sport is still young and is
still evolving right and while the UFC
is to some extent synonymous to Lee is a
promotion it's still
structured to some extent you know like
prize fighting right there's still
pay-per-view and even though there's
rankings sometimes you'll see the
rankings are not it's not a true
meritocracy because it's still prize
fighting and entertainment to some
extent right
um and and I think that they have come a
long way but they still have a long way
to go in terms of how much Fighters
should could earn should earn
um but at the end of the day too from a
boxing perspective I think that's why
boxing has been on the decline it's
still fragmented right and there's at
the end of the day there's not uh a true
promotion that's that's
stood the test of time I know top ranks
been around forever right but who do
they really have matching seems to be
doing more obviously Premiere is still
around and still PBC still competing but
you see it kind of fragmented right
Canelo fight for matching one one for
for a couple fights tonight fighting for
PVC for a fight
um and I and the difference is though I
think in boxing promotions could fight
each other and so they have to agree on
that right I think in the MMA it's going
to continue to evolve right you now have
um the ability can Conor do that of
course I think Connor is one of probably
the only person could carry his own show
it's very difficult to do right it's
hard to go
how many million pay-per-view sellers
are there in either sport not a lot you
know it's like it's it's not that easy
to do so I think that from a from a UFC
perspective they've always looked at it
as like look we're we're building
something that's sustainable and they
are correct in that regard but I think
that Fighters definitely should have a
bigger uh piece of the revenues as this
thing continues to grow which I think
they've come a long way but they still
have a long way to go right
this data is wrong every freaking time
have you heard of HubSpot
HubSpot is a CRM platform where
everything is fully integrated well I
can see the client's whole history calls
support tickets emails and here's a test
from three days ago I totally missed
HubSpot grow better
yeah I was going to say you know uh the
other group that's trying to do their
own shows is the kind of Jake Paul Logan
Paul style thing where they're doing
these kind of like kind of celebrity
matches High interest uh fights and
getting people to buy pay-per-views for
that seems to honestly be working like
you know like uh I don't know what you
think about those guys but I personally
used to be like oh you know kind of
wrote them off as this like kind of like
they were like in the jackass crowd of
like the YouTube generation of the fine
generation and then they said they were
going to do this boxing thing uh let's
see who knows how serious it'll take it
but honestly like they've done a good
job of actually like building up
interest and pulling these events off
and being like respectable showing up
very respectably uh and winning several
of these fights um you can't hate on
them man you can't hate on them they're
they're putting in the time actually our
client Dylan Dennis is fighting Logan
Paul coming up that's right Dylan Dennis
is your client yeah oh my God that is so
funny are you the genius behind his uh
current marketing strategy is that your
did you sign off on that no no that's
all I'm doing
um I thought you might have been his
client there's there's a famous video
where Nate Diaz and Dylan are getting
into it and Nate throws a beer on Dylan
and I saw you in the video trying to be
like the the father in the whole like
you're like hey Nate Dylan if you guys
please walk away is that good it didn't
work out my kids do it listen you know
so
um uh but no I you know you got to give
those guys credit I mean look I think
they're they're putting in time in their
crash they're they're going in there and
and they're not only you know taking a
shot risk it you know I could argue that
they're not really doing it against Real
boxers that's true you know I think
they're being more strategic and but you
know again credit has to go to
Connor right who created that Trend who
started that it was less versus
Mayweather and then now I mean even if
Floyd goes and fights someone else he
doesn't get the same result without it
being another two two a side guys facing
each other and well I give all of them
credit too I don't think you've seen
this Blockbuster event that anybody's
been hoping for so so at the end of the
day you know there's a market though
there's an appetite from a consumer to
go look at you know me and you Sean I
don't I think we may look at 100 people
that tune in but nonetheless there's a
market there probably streaming on
YouTube Sam is gonna have to pay he
doesn't get it under you underestimate
how many people want to see if we get my
today
my friend I think you're right you're
right so what are the they've been
begging to get Connor in that I think
that that's the white whale that Jake
Paul's chasing what is the percent
chance that a fight between Conor
McGregor and Jake Paul ever happens I
mean right now College focused on
Michael Chandler I'm saying I can tell
you floor and exploit the rematches is
there Logan Paul wants to fight him Jake
Paul not as well of possibilities not
zero yeah it's not zero it's just not
top of mind right now right so you need
to take up your sports jacket you need
to have a proper 12 you need to like I
want the non-polar politician answer
that you you
jizz are so good
that's funny it's like I wonder if I
just wore freaking Street wearing and
you know and and dyed my hair and
bleached my hair like I used to when I
was a young punk rock kid you know if
everybody would really just hear what
I'm saying this D is not I'm
just telling you the truth like if he's
gonna fight Michael Chandler next right
it's not and we're not thinking about
that you know what I mean but ultimately
of course we know he wants to fight of
course we know it's there and of course
I think if everybody keeps doing their
thing it's gonna be a market for it
right so well let's talk about the the
biggest of these freak Show fights right
now is Elon versus Zuck and it was one
of those things that like in our world's
like that's that's never happened in the
kind of business and Tech world and then
daily comes out and kind of certifies it
he's like no they want it to happen
we're talking to them we might make it
happen which was yeah but he always does
yeah well exactly it's Dana White so you
never know uh but you know it was
interesting that it got a little bit
more heat from that what's your take on
that and again same question
I don't know if data would have gone on
a limb if he hadn't really talked to
both right I mean do they well I'm sure
he talked to both but I don't I don't
think that he would have done that you
know and and even Zuck training with
freaking you know a bunch of different
Fighters Izzy and bulk and and Jon Jones
and and then uh Elon bringing in GSP and
do you believe it'll happen and if so I
believe stuck would be down yeah catch
weight whatever it doesn't matter I
agree like I think Zuck is down Zuck is
a is is is truly you know training and
regardless of this fight or not he's in
there does that mean you think Elon
might not be down because that's our
Theory here on this podcast is that Elon
wants to talk about it look from the
outside looking in and all the
information that I have which is
probably less than what you have being
in the tech world you guys have some
freaking secret telegram groups and
who told you about that dude for knowing
you or like knowing what I think of you
you're probably gonna be managing them
no I mean like hey I'll yeah I'm
definitely gonna pursue them you know
but so long as we get some rights not
just transactions we got to build
something together you know but I know
but I I I think it's up to Elon I truly
think it's up to you about you know and
I don't know do you think Dana came out
and said if it happened they probably
looked at the numbers though for both X
and threads they're like this is great
yeah
but zuck's more serious like no don't
talk about it I saw those text exchanges
and all that kind of stuff that kind of
were leaked and like I said
that's about it he's not he's not
bullshitting you know Dana has said if
it happens it would be the biggest fight
ever he thinks it would surpass
Floyd Pacquiao it would surpass Floyd
Connor he thinks it would be that
because it's just like uh you know the
freak of all freak shows in that sense
like it crosses over into so many
different like fan bases or domains you
get all the combat force people but
you'd also get the business people to
watch I think so I think so and I think
it would also be the saddest fight ever
yeah it'd also be really a lame to watch
but it was actually it was it was
actually it was actually kind of
up the way Elon was all about it and
then all of a sudden it's like it's not
going to be to you on stage it's going
to be charity like wait a second you
can't play along all this time
and then and then all of a sudden pull
the rug you know what I mean like yeah
did you see the video of him curling a
40 or he had like a 20 pound or 40 pound
weight at his office and he did a live
Twitter where he was he's like I'm
curling to prepare it's like no dude I
swear to God if you think doing curls at
your desk is how you prepare you're this
is not going to be good
man you know oh I didn't see that that's
funny that's hilarious dude I want to
ask let me ask you about some other
slick guys so basically a lot of people
who don't watch the UFC they don't know
that uh so Dana's the front guy you know
he's doing a lot of the match setting
and uh he does all the talking and he
seems like a wonderful businessman but
the Fertitta Brothers interests me most
because they were uh I think I think
Dana only owned like four or six percent
of it when it sold but the Fertitta
brothers owned most all of it besides
some outside outside money because they
were already wealthy but they seem like
those guys they don't do a lot of
interviews and they're a little bit
behind the scenes they seem like sharks
have you learned anything interesting
from uh uh the two brothers and Dana uh
about business well so obviously look
the they sold their business now right
Endeavor ended up yeah you know William
Morris at the time they they bought it
um but I I had uh pleasure of being able
to to you know deal across from Lorenzo
Fertitta on particularly uh on a couple
clients particularly Connor obviously at
that level
um and they're very Savvy businessmen
very very composed you know I I it's not
it's the the dynamic when I'm on the
opposite side naturally it's adversarial
a lot of the time right and so
um you know at the end of the day I'm
advocating for my clients so it's it's
I'm not their best friend right it's not
like they're going to invite me over for
Christmas and and uh but but we do have
we did have a respectful relationship
and I really really enjoyed dealing with
someone you know that that has been not
only successful in our Sport and the
Pioneer in it but was a super successful
businessman in the casino business and
other businesses as well so you learn
you learn from the interactions and the
dealings and the negotiations that
you're you're you're doing like for
example when Mayweather McGregor it
happened and we we basically got what we
were leaving or striving for from a
negotiation like Connor and I really we
had that moment when we walked out of
Lorenzo's office we're like you
did it you know it was like a moment
right and so do you guys like keep a
straight face until you get to the
parking lot yeah you get like Giddy and
start hugging it well in the
meeting in in the office you have the
smirk you know you don't give it away
right and then yeah when you get in the
car yeah you celebrate you know
um but yeah man I think it's the human
I think that's what people don't
realize I mean it's like it's the same
in all sectors all sports and even the
most composed person that doesn't do any
interviews I'm sure I've had those
moments in their own you know Journeys
as well right I read on um front office
Sports I think it's called it's like a
sports publication that the final exit
for uh proper 12 was 600 million dollars
and I think that was only four years
after you started it it's 600 million
dollars in the ballpark three years and
I can tell you you listen if it's
probably printed then you've got to go
with that because I can't necessarily
comment on the specific numbers but
we're still involved too it's not you
know at the end of the day it's it's we
we're still you know part of the team
we're still pushing it to grow the brand
we just came out with a news flavor our
Irish Apple flavor which is amazing
um you know dangerously amazing amazing
too because I you know you just it
drinks it goes down so easy uh but yeah
man I'm super proud of that was that was
that like a new level for you wealth
wise and what I mean or were you able to
make money a little bit along the way
you know I think that was a whole nother
level right that was a whole nother
level where you're able to
achieve you know
your your your your your you know your
ultimate goals right but ultimately too
you're you're you're proving your
content you know what I mean like
ultimately like we're not having to go
sell the platform we're creating
liquidity events by creating
opportunities
um left and right not just for clients
now we're creating Ventures that are you
know creative to the platform we have a
a smart basketball technology called
hoop we have uh you know some other
adventures in the pipeline that are
coming out that are very very much
focused on on advocacy for the entire
Sport and creating something where we're
putting our own capital in these things
to create opportunities for everybody
else right and so and and there's other
things that we're creating specifically
for our clients right so so you know in
lieu of of uh of of of of you know
having the opportunity to invest or you
know an athlete not maybe not having the
brand Equity to go start their own
Venture how can we bring them along to
ride with us you know for for the next
Paw Patrol if you will right I always
like to ask people this because
I remember you know when you start out
in business typically you have kind of
nothing to your name and you've got this
literally nothing credit card debt like
exactly nothing so you start at zero or
usually you go below zero you dip below
zero for way below zero
well the funny thing is and this is what
people don't appreciate like my wife now
she was my girlfriend and she had a job
and we were literally maxed out credit
cards and for the first seven years of
Paradigm I didn't take a paycheck I was
paying team members and staff before I
was paying myself
and I think people lose sign to that you
know it's like but but then when you
have huge success you still try to do
right take care of people but even
that's sometimes no good deed goes
unpunished right but ultimately the it's
a war of attrition you have to be able
to withstand all of it and really
believe in what you're doing and you
know eat sandwiches daily right on
your way there you're not a meeting at
you you eat these sandwiches for in
your case seven years in my case I
remember like sort of eight or nine
years straight of just uh like in my
case it's just kind of failure but like
in your case at least you're building it
up
um and then you finally have the moment
where it's kind of like validated
realize a Payday comes in you get a
windfall along the way and
like financially sure that's exciting
and things change at a logical level but
before it hits the logical level there's
kind of the emotional level of like what
does that feel like
um what thoughts go through your head at
that time we had a guy come on the Pod
he's like dude I used to just every day
for the next week I just drove to the
bank and I would just go in the ATM put
my card in and say print receipt because
I just wanted to see it and he's always
like I didn't even have anything James
Hong he's like I didn't even have
anything I wanted to spend it on he's
like I was just amazed I was just
amazing to look at that because I knew
the seven year or whatever the the years
that go into not not being there not
having that and we had other people that
are like you know this is oddly numb
feeling I didn't feel anything and other
people were like you know I had a
conversation with myself I said all
right now I'm here here's this pivotal
conversation I had myself so I always
like to ask people about that moment
because I think there's usually
something interesting that happens it's
not just like just another day so it's
surreal to me because you know on on one
end it happened during covet so it was a
real it was a weird time
for all of us right and you know you you
you you you you get there and honestly
it's like you're pinching yourself and
you know because it's a new age you
don't have to necessarily go to the bank
account to print the receipt anywhere
you can just look at that I certainly
did that a few times just like what you
know uh but also like you have to make
decisions like I we we hired more people
we gave people raise we gave people
bonuses that had nothing to do with them
with that part of the business and and
we invested back in the business and so
I was first thing I bought was my mom my
house and a car and so I like you know I
I was trying to really
you know stay grounded you know what I
mean and more importantly like try to do
right you know as best as you can
um by for for those that are important
to you both
um family and on your team right and
ultimately
um still like just enjoy the moment and
because we were kind of everybody locked
in at home
it was you know every night it was for
my wife and I was just surreal and it's
like you know then you start to think
about okay well you tell your kids do
you not how do you raise them the right
way and how do you make sure you keep
them hungry and humble and you know what
I mean it's not about that and a lot of
things change right because it's like
you get there and you start to realize
um you got to start planning thinking
and and acting differently but then also
other unintended issues start to come up
you know like you know that was I forgot
Mo Money Mo Problems is true you know at
the end of the day uh what problems just
a lot of different things I think people
want people want people think
that they deserve uh unappreciative
people no matter what you give them you
know they just unfortunately have a
self-inflated view
um you know I think there's there's a
whole list of issues that come up with
it right uh
that's the reality but it is you gotta
take the good the bad the ugly and just
keep rolling punches and level up and
level up and evolve that's what it is I
thought you were gonna say you had a red
panty night I was I was waiting for it
that was the
you said it for me I did
and you had two bites of the apple right
if I remember correctly like I think you
guys did you guys sell a portion of the
business early on and I think you sold
half of it and then yeah another I don't
know if it was the half or the rest or
another big chunk yeah right yep was it
a hard decision to sell or did you have
600 million reasons I mean
it was I mean look any first of all it
was an amazing at the time but I always
ask the fact you're like now we still
have we're still part of the business so
we can still keep making a lot of money
in in into the next decade or and longer
you know at the end of the day
um because uh it's always difficult to
think about oh Woulda Shoulda Coulda
right but you got to be able to count
you know the fortunes of it all
um you know and and be grounded and and
that positive reality it's not a
negative thing you know it's very easy
to always Monday Morning Quarterback
something like oh we shouldn't have sold
because this this and now but you have
those regrets which I think is normal by
the way I think most people who no maybe
most I think who they sell but you you
all if you sell it right you tend to
sell early right I mean that tends to
happen I think I think the way we
structured the deal allows us to really
not only we made a ton of money but we
just continue to make a ton of money and
and you know ultimately have I had those
thoughts sure you always think about it
and because it's for me it's more so
okay
it's about execution right so not only
did we execute but then how's how's the
deal how's the terms how's this how's
that you know so I'm kind of like
constantly watching the film to make
sure that I'm learning and growing as an
entrepreneur because I'm not resting on
my Laurels either I'm not done right and
so I'm I'm still playing the game while
you play the game you got to be able to
not only celebrate the victories but
watch the tape back and see where you
could have gotten better right that's
the only way you're going to be the best
at what you do so I have a partner who a
business partner who basically he was he
was already successful before but his
second company he was about to get a 200
million dollar check for the sale and it
was a like a one of those like
clickbaity websites on Facebook that
showed like top 10 lists and then
Facebook changed the algorithm and the
sale sale dropped from 200 million to
like 30 million and it was just a
massive issue because of platform risk
and there's a lot of fear of platform
risk do you do you view Connor as like
your platform risk like if he really
because he gets in trouble uh sometimes
and he gets accused of a lot of stuff
sometimes maybe he actually did do it
sometimes he didn't do it do you get
nervous about platform risk with Conor
of like if he does something really
bad I'm I'm yeah well he's been
accused of a lot of things and he's
never been that's that's the the facts
right uh but obviously there's always
risk and everything and I think when you
look at you know such a you know
Connor's kind of like an enigma right so
there's certainly going to be uh those
that may be reverse and not want to do
anything but at the end of the day
whoever gets involved with us
understands the McGregor brand right and
understands inherent risks that
potentially come with that but
ultimately they also look at the track
record and that is always going to win
the day right because you could make all
these claims accusation whatever but
ultimately
with the facts of the facts and the
results are the results and the data is
the data so I think when you look at all
those things some of all parts is why we
have a healthy relationship with all of
our business partners and we continue to
incubate and launch other exciting
businesses and around the Connor brand
for me he's the biggest client he's the
he's also the top one percent you know
pop culture brand in the world so it's
like unless I go inside the other people
in that small
uh bucket if you will he's yeah he's
always going to have uh you know that
that let's call it you know uh
proportionate risk value across my
platform right but ultimately we're also
you know much more than just one client
and we're building something that for me
is into the future right Sean do you see
what happened with Barstool so basically
Barstool Sports sold to a Betting
Company a pen pen yeah and I don't
remember the final sale 600 million plus
Dave made a killing thank you guys stock
nothing right a lot of stock yeah he got
a lot of stock I think he got some uh I
think he was able to sell some I know I
know that the the on Wall Street you
could see that he did sell a little bit
and he um basically after three years
pen was like
you guys are insane like you're
it's really hard for us to do like
because we're regulated as a casino it's
really hard to let you do what you want
to do without hurting us and ESPN wants
to do this big deal with us but they
won't do it for with Barstool you know
what Dave here look just have the
company back and if you ever sell it
again we get half of the profit cool and
in exchange we're gonna do this ESPN
deal which is going to boost our stock
we're good it was like the the greatest
coup of all time of like you know Dave
getting uh Dave selling it and then them
just saying here actually we don't want
this uh you know maybe we have a world
where the buyer of proper 12 is like hey
this was cool and all but you know what
you could just have it it's yours now
yeah I think it was brilliant it's a
great move for him and I think he still
has pen stock too so then the stock goes
up but he's winning again so good for
him uh yeah that then that's a that's an
interesting sector where we're getting
ready to enter into it that's uh I'm
interested to see what they do with it
now right barstools and see what they
end up through the end up you know
partnering with to try to get that off
the ground you probably I'm guessing you
kind of studied other people who had
Talent like this like I don't know if
you're in a group chat with like Scooter
Braun and like you know Don Shahidi or
some of these guys that are managing you
know the sort of the big scores those
same top one percent kind of like people
who can move the needle John's and
John's of John's a friend I don't know
scooter but John's a friend who's John
what's his last name the guy who manages
the health boys now
um oh yeah yeah
a dozen or so of some of the top
podcasts and personalities you know he's
a he's a he's certainly a entrepreneur I
respect and he um and so you you kind of
study them a little bit if somebody was
studying you and they see what you're
doing with Conor and how you built like
I'm just gonna name them off so you did
the Whiskey brand proper 12. you have
Netflix documentaries and like
entertainment that way you have Road
House which is the new movie coming out
you have the August McGregor the the
suit lines you have title which is like
the recovery spray you have the fast app
which is like Fitness like app uh plus
and I think like Jim's coming or
whatever like you know something like
that like a fitness brand that obviously
fits there we have actually have a event
based uh competition coming three called
3ko so that's gonna be you know think of
of Spartan Race meets meets meets uh
CrossFit Games you know very cool so you
have that you have uh I think it's like
a mobile game that he's in you do like
kind of the the silver fight with
Mayweather there's all these different
things you've done around that person
that brand and I'm sure some of them
worked amazingly and some of them
probably were too much work for what
they were worth you just you learn as
you go right you're not I doubt you were
the one entrepreneur who just magically
had everything right from day one no no
way right so if somebody was studying
you or somebody had you know it was it
was hat was with the next McGregor was
it with another star Creator would you
what would be your kind of like advice
to that person how would you advise them
based on your learnings of the last 10
years of trying to figure this out yeah
I mean first and foremost I'm still
learning right I'm still learning I'm
still growing what I would say is you
know you have to be ready to uh you know
not only dream but act on those dreams
right and come prepared from a research
and preparation perspective building out
a plan and being fluid because it's not
always going to go to plan right but if
you're prepared and you do have a plan
you're you're likely more you know
you're likely to execute even if you
have to deviate a little bit because you
have to stay fluid with what reality
hits you with right
um You have to also have thick skin man
like at the end of the day it's a war of
attrition you're gonna eat
sandwiches daily for a long time and so
you got to be able to withstand that
with a smile but be able to see through
all the noise the pressure and more
importantly have that ability to
communicate with that with that client
right because you guys have to stay in
sync in terms of what you're building
um I would say you know one of the
things I wish I would have done build a
team around you that's more experienced
than you right because ultimately I
think that that's what's going to allow
you to accelerate your plan as opposed
to Bringing people and then having to do
other with other things like those
people turning on you well what were one
reason or not how big is the Paradigm
team it's still Boutique so we're about
15 on the whole code level but then
every brand Coast you will uh has has
its own respective team right
um and what I would also say is you know
don't don't stop innovating right
um don't stop trying to create
new opportunities that have to align
right with your client right organically
but you got to make sure you're able to
clearly Define that what's your criteria
so like you've gone into these 10
different categories how do you pick
which category to go into what what is
it
the line organically right and they have
to have a genuine interest because you
can't sell something that's fake I mean
everybody thought and it's another thing
everybody thought proper 12 was going to
be a gimmick until they tried it
obviously if you don't drink you don't
drink but if you try it oh my God this
is great make sure we created a
substantive brand right it wasn't going
to be just something that we just put
his face on it and try to sell and
that's important I know to him as well
and that's why he believes in in in the
ventures that that that that he's
involved with he's very passive but it's
they're of substance as well they're
quality so you have to understand the
market you have to understand the
players in the market you have to
understand how you fit in or how you can
disrupt the marketing grab market share
and you have to put a plan together that
allows you to to have a higher
probability of success with the black
belts that are going to help you operate
the business you know and then having
all the other components that making
sure that you could actually build a
product or service or substance by the
way did you ever consider just putting
his name on it it's like you have like
uh Jameson or Johnny Walker or Jack
Daniels like McGregor's name is so
famous it's interesting decisions they
actually take it's taken I did think
about that there's a the McGregor Clan I
think it's the scotch I'm not mistaken
so that that was certainly considered we
we also considered notorious Irish
whiskey at one point right
um and and you know again even early
earlier days
a couple other things that were floated
around but no proper 12's a good name
Paw Patrol is good again what's it mean
like the choice is it like the 12
districts of like Dublin Dublin 12. so
each let's call it yeah Borough or city
within Dublin is is a number and where
he's from is Dublin 12. and so and
proper I mean they always say that was a
proper night out you know like oh it's
proper good time and
um so it's you know proper number 12.
that just made sense for the brand and
again after pivoting several groups and
finding the right Partners you know we
came up with the brand together and Sean
and I are big fans of of words you know
like we'll hear someone say something
and we're like oh man the language they
used was beautiful that was really good
language whether it's writing or just
someone talking
the cool thing about Connors he he's got
a beautiful vocabulary and beautiful
timing and beautiful phrasing so he uses
wonderful words and so like I remember
when he was fighting Jose Aldo he would
talk about like he was like if this was
another time I would storm your pavilla
and then he like talks about like what
he would do to the and uh like he like
you know the whole red panty night like
he just has like really funny catchy
phrases I guess Trump kind of did this
too where he just like it was just
really catchy stuff are you guys ever
just shooting the and you're like
oh that's a line we're going to we're
gonna have to use that
um very natural and going back to the
Acumen I mean that is stuff that it's
not rehearsed it's very much stuff that
he just comes up with but we'd be there
and he'd say some stuff like that was
hilarious that's another that's another
mcgregor-ism you know what I mean like
you're like put that in the bank use
that one I have two fan service
questions that are around that number
one yeah well during the Mayweather
press tour uh which was just like that
was that was so much fun but it looked
like because all UFC press tours are the
same you go you sit and they ask you
questions and then you react whereas
that one was like stand up and give a
speech and it almost looked like Conor
was almost ambushed like oh I just got
to give a 20-minute improvised speech in
front of millions of people right now
and then they kind of did it was that an
ambush I always wondered yeah no idea
what the format was going to be like and
Sam yes it was exactly at the time but
just thinking back to it every time it
kind of comes up from whether it's the
annual anniversary whatever it may be it
was such a great experience man and it
was like once in a lifetime thing
because you know Sean there was no
format that's your point I don't know if
you felt ambushed but certainly we're
like oh what how is it for this one how
is it for that one right but the energy
of all of them was out of this world and
so I think that they fed off that energy
which gave them the ability to deliver
these legendary lines and answered back
and forth I remember watching it and it
was clear that he was like wait there's
no questions I just have to I
just have have to go okay I'm a comedian
now all right bet and he said this line
he goes you know they they've tried
everything they didn't tell us the
format my microphone doesn't work
they're trying to put me in a
uncomfortable situation but they don't
know I thrive in uncomfortable
situations I almost feel like he was
giving himself a pep talk during the
speech I I really loved that line that
was that was great but I also have
another kind of fan service question on
almost the other side of the coin so as
you can tell me and Sam both fans of you
of the UFC of Conor like we really it'll
take a lot of inspiration from some of
the you know it's just a badass thing to
go out there and just fight and and put
yourself on the line like that every
single time there's something to be
admired with that for sure and I think
Conor came in with a very
uh like at the beginning how could you
hate the guy like he was he was bold he
came from nowhere he was like you know
this guy who was like a you know
Apprentice plumber and then was like all
of a sudden beating everybody exactly
this way he said he would his fighting
style was electric like there was
nothing to dislike about the guy I
thought on the on the come up uh I'm
sure some people did but like the
majority of fans I think were were on
the come up were just like this guy's
incredible and then there's sort of
almost like a heel turn now where um I
know a lot of people who I watch fights
with they sort of feel like he's kind of
jumped the shark like oh you know now
he's this like
first of all she's like super jacked now
in this huge way he's like more of a
boxer he's he hasn't fought in a long
time you know he talks tracking maybe
he's crossing the line too much oh he's
getting in trouble like there's all
these things honestly like I know he's
your client and he's your friend and
you're probably never gonna say a bad
word about it but I think there are some
Fair criticisms that like you know it's
understandable why somebody who was a
super fan might now feel like ah you
know I can't really you know get behind
everything that I'm that I'm seeing here
um
do you think about that at all and do
you uh I guess like what's your reaction
to that I I don't really know how to
phrase the question but I feel like
you're one of the few people on Earth
who would have an opinion about this
that I would really care to hear I mean
look it's just like you are engaged with
these conversations naturally I'm gonna
hear everything right from people around
me and you know whether it's my friends
whether it's family and ultimately what
I'll say is this like you know
everybody's entitled to their own
opinion I know who the person is and
obviously I I do have an intimate
relationship it's something that's more
than just transactionals more than just
a client a business partner someone that
I I'm I'm loyal Tunes been loyal to me
and so at the end of the day you know I
know that history once it's done being
written
will be interpreted by everybody
differently he's definitely not perfect
he's definitely made mistakes but a lot
of the criticism too is subjective it's
based on where where you stand and what
you believe in or what you want to see
Etc but AKA never been legally all those
accusations have not been legally found
to be true right B it was the cleanest
and the most tested athlete before he
got out of these shadow pool and when he
returns to fighting he's going to do it
the right way and everything's going to
be legal so everybody can say what they
want to say there's nothing that was
done wrong right and so he's he's
constantly being vilified because
ultimately the stuff that they love them
for he still does the all outspoken
they'll says what's on the top of his
mind but maybe because he has the riches
now and it's not the rags anymore
sometimes we try to tear some people
down I don't know why I can't tell you
right but ultimately I do know proofs in
the puddin he has to continue to go out
there and show that he could continue to
evolve be the best version of himself
not just athletically but as a human
being as well and ultimately that's on
him to do and I can't do that for him
you can't do that for him but criticism
is going to come and when you're when
you're in the public eye you got to be
ready to to take it on and at the end of
the day Heavy's the head that wears the
crown you can't just want the good and
not take the bad with it so ultimately
that's something that we constantly talk
about something that I know he says I
say to him we talk about he understands
that but it doesn't make it easy it
doesn't make it easy because ultimately
at least like you know you know you talk
about that that aha moment I don't know
how many entrepreneurs you've had on
this podcast but when they have that big
moment they don't need to be seen by
everybody they're probably enjoying it
with nobody watching them or if they go
somewhere nobody really recognizing who
they are right myself included so
ultimately it's very desperate and
um that doesn't you know you can
essentially absolve him of the
responsibility that he has to take upon
himself in certain instances but more
importantly it makes me understand
pressure is real not only to win and
succeed but on another level to live
your life so visibly for everybody to
just critique every little thing in
today's world man everybody has an
opinion you know you guys before you met
me you thought I was a square suit
because of how I appeared physically
visually to you without ever talking to
me before right so it's like very easy
than fast judgment based on whatever
your belief system is how you're raised
your experiences with someone that look
like me whatever it may be or your
opinions of Agents just because you
watch Entourage and parlors but I I
can't change that ultimately right and
so when you live in today's world like
that for everybody to critique man it's
gonna come with now just the good but
the bad the ugly as well you got to deal
with it I like the fan questions you
know this is it's fun we've had Ariel
hawani on here uh you know we've become
friendly with Ben asper and I think
we've talked to Mike Mike Bisping we've
talked to a bunch of folks it's uh you
know Sean and I are super fans so it's
always fun to like get like The Insider
how many fights have you guys been to in
person I've only been to three or four
the the the in-person event is
definitely like the best in-person
sporting event but in my opinion if
you're like a uh like a a nerd and a fan
fan it's so much better to hear the
commentary and to see it on uh and just
like to see like the replay of the Sean
Malley uh knockout uh on Saturday like
it was really awesome to be able to like
see it close up you know one challenge
with UFC which is that the cage and the
cameraman on every post of the cage does
kind of screw up the viewing experience
depending on where you're at like I'm
sure if you're right next to right
ringside it maybe you don't have that
issue but like we went to one event at
the the Vegas Place uh the one where
um mosvidol need Aspirin into like you
know you know the next realm and uh
and you know the guy I saw it but the
guy next to me like literally couldn't
even see the thing he missed the moment
because it was like a split it was like
in the first five seconds of the fight
and secondly like you know just because
of a cage like if you go to a football
game or a basketball game it's open
field it's you know it's very easy to
see what's going on whereas you're
almost watching on the dumbotron well
it's interesting first of all I think
look there are pros and cons to your
both your points the energy of a big
fights is something else it's electric I
mean just the walkouts and the crowd and
you steal it and then you hear the thuds
and you know it's like it's it's pretty
pretty amazing I was at uh Jorge and
Nate and it was like spectacular right
it just it's just nice to be able to
like you got to go home and watch it
again yeah yeah but then from A View
perspective to your point unless you're
like the first few rows of the floor
it's actually that the the the mid low
Riser which is the perfect view because
you're looking into the Octagon but
you're still really fairly close and I
think that's the best you live right but
um nonetheless no matter where your
seats are I think for big big events you
the the electricity of that place is
something else you know
so what's gonna happen like I'm
following this whole circus with Dylan
danis and Logan I have I've never even
seen Dylan Danish train I went and
watched his two Bellator fights but that
was like years ago what's gonna happen
like I don't know I've never even seen
Spar or anything on like leading up
videos what's gonna happen uh on that
one said August it's August 14th Logan
is is obviously has a uh uh a leg up
having you know box before right yeah
that was years ago I think he's bigger
no listen listen I I get it uh uh you
know the fight's actually scheduled
October 14th but but oh October Dylan
has made all the necessary
necessary adjustments to his life to his
preparation but this is his boxing debut
so he has to go in there and really
prove it right now I could tell you the
banter that's going back and forth I
mean you know he's confident in his
abilities and he's definitely putting in
the work so ultimately you don't you
don't make you know you don't take that
position with the banter that he's doing
if you're not going in there with some
level of confidence in yourself right so
and and I and I'm sure it's giving Logan
a little bit more training for it right
because ultimately it's it's personal
now I would imagine right
um oh yeah not even Conor you know king
of Trash Talk counter wouldn't even he
never even went that far uh to talk
about family I don't like that he's
talking about family but I like it in
the sense of like I'm gonna stare at it
I have a kid on the internet and I think
it's funny too you know yeah
yeah like it's too far but at the same
time like but it's there you know what I
mean I'm watching that I think what's
interesting is the you know love it or
hate it the engagement for that is
through the roof and you know it should
help show the fight and more importantly
like it's about now performing right
because ultimately you can talk all you
want now you got to go on the phone but
he's made all the adjustments to his
life personally professionally which
which I'm very proud of him for doing
that will give him that that high chance
of winning this I think he's gonna yes
and shock a lot of people people are not
giving him enough credit I think when he
gets in there it's it's just time to
shine now he's putting he's gonna put
he's gonna basically put his money where
his mouth is because the mouth is
getting it ready is going to make people
want to watch him love him right well
you're you're kind of implying you're
like well it doesn't matter unless he
loses and uh I kind of disagree I think
uh I think he's already won whether he
loses or or not like he's he's already
kind of like from where he was starting
to where he is now like you know he's
already gotten he'll be okay he'll even
if he gets knocked out right away he'll
probably be better off than where he was
oh this is a great opportunity for him
no doubt no doubt thanks for doing this
man uh where should people follow you if
they want to get more just uh my first
and last name at auditar Twitter
Instagram threads
sorry yeah sorry yeah at audience
audience threads audiot Instagram I
think one of three still remain
all right Audi thanks for doing this man
all right just Sean Sam thank you so
much appreciate it and that's the pod
[Music]